va pas parler de votre rapport mesdames
rappeur choc du Sénat sur l'industrie
porno d'abord un mot avec vous Steve les
grandes lignes oui porno l'enfant du
décor vous l'avez dit Oriane c'est le
titre de ce rapport très dense ça va
port inédit à plusieurs égards c'est
tout simplement la première fois dans
l'histoire parlementaire qui rapporte se
penche sur les pratiques de l'industrie
pornographique alors de quoi parle-t-on
et bien d'un business qui est décrit
comme massif et mondialisé un business
qui génère plusieurs milliards d'euros
au profit de quelques multinationales
souvent domiciliés dans des paradis
fiscaux il faut savoir que nous la
France on est le quatrième pays le plus
consommateur de porno au monde en termes
de consultation journalière les français
effectuent chaque mois un total de plus
de 650 millions de visites sur
l'ensemble des sites accessibles dans le
monde cette Français sur 10
consulteraient mensuellement au moins
une plateforme c'est beaucoup à tel
point que vous parlez d'une consommation
massive banalisée et toxique et cette
consommation ne concerne pas que les
adultes deux tiers des enfants de moins
de 15 ans et un tiers des moins de 12
ans ont déjà été volontairement ou
involontairement exposé à des images
pornographiques prêts d'un tiers un
tiers des garçons de moins de 15 ans
seront sur un site porno au moins une
fois par mois tout ça en violation du
code pénal qui incrimine le fait et bien
qu'un message à caractère pornographique
soit vu par un mineur on va bien sûr on
en parler de ces chiffres qui sont assez
alarmants mais d'abord je voulais vous
demander si vous le rappeler c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire
parlementaire que des parlementaires se
penchent sur l'industrie pornographique
pourquoi vous avez voulu travailler sur
ce sujet Laurence Cohen et comment vous
expliquer que ça n'ait pas été fait
avant écoutez nous avons voulu
travailler sur le sujet parce que vous
avez vu qu'à la délégation droit des
femmes au Sénat on a beaucoup travaillé
sur les violences faites aux femmes donc
on a été alerté par des associations
féministes et puis ça s'est passé à un
moment donné aussi où il y a eu des
affaires qui ont éclaté et des
poursuites judiciaires donc il nous est
apparu absolument important de faire ce
travail on y a réfléchi et nous sommes
quatre co-rapporteurs et je dois de
sensibilité politique différente comme
vous l'avez souligné et on a trouvé très
facilement un consensus mais pas du tout
un consensus mou un consensus exigeant
parce que nous avons toute considéré que
ce sont des violences qui sont
minimisées ça n'est pas du cinéma les
actes que l'on voit sont des actes qui
ne sont pas simulés on va évidemment on
va en parler comment vous avez travaillé
alexandra Burke fondant tout au long de
ces mois sur ce rapport on a travaillé
pendant un peu plus de six mois on a
auditionné toute la sphère justement
importante pour nous pour nourrir notre
réflexion que ce soit des chercheurs des
médecins bien sûr des procureurs des
acteurs des victimes aussi beaucoup donc
voilà on avait besoin de d'entendre
toutes les parties prenantes de cette
industrie pour pouvoir faire un état des
lieux puisque le rapport c'est ça
finalement c'est de faire un état des
lieux avec des recomm qui on l'espère
pourront aboutir justement sur une
proposition de loi et des et faire
évoluer justement la législation à la
matière est-ce que vous attendiez est-ce
que vous avez découvert durant ces six
mois de travaux
écoutez-moi en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne j'ai été vraiment
particulièrement frappé par les
témoignages des des victimes ou
d'ailleurs on a du mal à parler
d'acteurs et d'actrices quand on entend
les témoignages parce qu'ils sont
vraiment extrêmement poignants il y a
des témoignages donc de viol de
violences psychologiques de violences
sexuelles il y a une considération de la
femme comme étant une femme objet et ce
que je veux souligner en tout cas et ça
apparaît dans notre rapport c'est qu'on
voit bien que c'est on est face à un
système un système qui fait partie des
violences qui sont infligées aux femmes
et on a pu constater vraiment une
porosité entre la prostitution et la
pornographie et surtout souligner que
c'est un marché extrêmement juteux que
il y a des milliards d'euros qui sont en
jeu et qui sont cachés dans les paradis
fiscaux et que ceux qui produisent
refuse pour beaucoup se fige pas mal des
contenus se fiche pas mal du vécu des
femmes ce qu'il les intéresse c'est ce
qu'ils vont toucher à la fin le porno
c'est plus une affaire de sexe et une
affaire d'argent aujourd'hui clairement
ah bah écoutez c'est ce qu'on cas on a
on a vu mais c'est une affaire d'argent
mais il y a des victimes qui sont
majoritairement des femmes et qui sont
vraiment en souffrance et elles nous ont
apporté des témoignages particulièrement
poignants puisque on a été à huis clos
pour l'une des auditions tellement
c'était difficile et on va entendre un
témoignage notamment d'une actrice tout
à l'heure vous avez beaucoup travaillé
sur la question des mineurs vous plus
particulièrement si vous rappelez des
chiffres qui sont assez alarmants sur le
nombre de consultations sur l'âge des
consultations est-ce que là aussi vous
attendiez à ça vous avez été un peu
concernés par ces chiffres sur les
mineurs alors c'est sûr que les chiffres
viennent un peu appuyer une vérité alors
je suis maire de famille aussi avec des
adolescents à la maison on en parle donc
je sais qu'ils ont accès à tout ça tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont un
smartphone aujourd'hui la plupart des
enfants un smartphone à partir du CM2
donc nous nous faisons aussi des
recommandations justement pour essayer
peut-être que le contrôle parental soit
installé par exemple par défaut dans un
abonnement de téléphone je crois qu'il
faut sensibiliser aussi via à l'école
via les cours notamment de SVT de lors
d'un déplacement dans un collège
d'Île-de-France sont certains
enseignants ont fait le choix pendant
les cours d'éducation sexuelle aussi de
sensibiliser les adolescents justement à
la violence que peuvent perpétrer
et bien le visionnage de vidéo
pendant un fixe donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut vraiment essayer
de renforcer alors vous savez qu'il y a
un article justement du code pénal qui
empêche qui est censé empêcher les sites
internet de diffuser du contenu
pornographique au mineur c'est
absolument pas respecté on vous dit
censé c'est bien ça le problème
exactement donc la loi n'est pas
appliquée donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
là aussi on fait des recommandations
pour donner plus de moyens à l'arcom
notamment aux agents qui puissent
sanctionner aussi les diffuseurs et puis
mettre en place les outils concrets
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut il
suffit juste de répondre à la question
et vous depuis 18 ans pour accéder à du
contenu je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus tolérable qu'on accepte ce genre
voilà de situations donc on propose des
solutions il existe des outils des
reconnaissances faciales qui a un nom
près peuvent calculer l'âge du visiteur
donc voilà des outils qui sont déjà
disponibles et qui ont besoin
aujourd'hui d'être mis en place pour
protéger nos enfants qu'un adolescent
un psychologue nous disait qu'un
adolescent qui par curiosité a besoin
d'aller voir des images de pornographie
quelque part c'est presque sain par
contre qu'il aille chercher de solutions
c'est là où le bât blesse est là où il
peut y avoir des conséquences
psychologiques une représentation de la
sexualité très compliqué pour eux avec
des conséquences sur les enfants mais
aussi sur les adultes
Laurence Cohen ce rapport ainsi sur les
principales victimes de cette industrie
ce sont les actrices oui des femmes
souvent précaires souvent fragiles qui
sont utilisés comme des objets pour
faire de l'argent le rapport monte très
bien comment les violences sexuelles
physiques et verbales ne sont pas
exception mais bien la norme vous
écrivez que ces violences revêtent un
caractère systémique 90% des scènes
pornographiques comporterait ainsi des
violences envers les femmes le rapport
par le même d'une machine à broyer les
femmes puisque la plupart du temps une
fois que ces vidéos sont mises en ligne
et bien elles ne sont jamais retirées
même quand une femme en demande
explicitement le retrait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les produits producteur
poussent les femmes à signer des
contrats de cession de droit à l'image
illimité et que si et bien on leur
demande d'enlever une vidéo les
réclament entre 3000 et 5000 euros c'est
dix fois plus que la rémunération
obtenue pour tourner la scène en
question des scènes qui sont décrites de
manière parfois très cru hein dans ce
rapport il y a beaucoup de témoignages
de femmes qui disent souffrir au
quotidien après avoir accepté de
participer à un tournage elles ont été
victimes de pratiques sexuelles non
consenties de violence physique pouvant
aller jusqu'au viol encore une fois il
ne s'agit pas d'une exception mais bien
de la norme selon votre rapport vous
avez même cette phrase
la pornographie constitue aujourd'hui à
l'évidence un élément important de la
culture du viol dans notre société c'est
une phrase forte
c'est une phrase effectivement forte
parce que c'est ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
constaté et on voit bien que je le
disais c'est un système on est dans un
système patriarcal et là ce sont les
violences qui sont poussées à l'extrême
et par rapport aux mineurs puisque on a
travaillé toutes les quatre sur
l'ensemble du livre sans se consacrer à
une partie plutôt qu'à une autre mais
vraiment on a abordé tous les sujets et
on constate par exemple que les mineurs
qui consomment beaucoup de pornographie
et bien pour eux ça aussi une
banalisation de la prostitution des
mineurs donc il y a des corrélations et
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
ce rapport à la fois pour permettre que
il n'y ait plus cette zone de non droit
parce que on assiste effectivement une
zone de l'endroit quand on dit oui les
mineurs on vérifie non on vérifie pas
l'âge on verra on vérifie pas l'âge
puisque il suffit de cliquer qu'on a
plus de 18 ans pour avoir accès à à des
images pornographiques extrêmement
violentes et je veux souligner également
que le but du rapport c'est de
responsabiliser les producteurs les
diffuseurs mais celles et ceux qui
regardent parce que ce que nous ont dit
un certain nombre de producteurs de
diffuseurs c'est il y a une demande donc
on répond à la demande et la demande
elle est de plus en plus sur ce qu'on
appelle le Gonzo c'est à dire quelque
chose de trash de hard et il faut
beaucoup de violence et il y a une
addiction à la pornographie on a pu le
constater par les témoignages de
psychologue de neuroscientifiques etc
donc voilà c'est ça qu'il faut faire
comprendre au grand public et ça veut
dire qu'il y a aussi une responsabilité
citoyenne c'est aussi ça l'objet de
notre rapport tout à fait les gens qui
regardent un film porno ne savent
peut-être pas ce qui se cache derrière
certains industrie et c'est aussi ça que
vous avez voulu mettre en lumière pour
alerter le citoyen c'est tout à fait ça
c'est à dire que et c'est vous savez
dans la prostitution quand il y a eu la
loi de 2016 on a responsabilisé aussi le
client et donc il y a eu tout un
éventail au niveau de la loi donc bien
au niveau de la pornographie il faut
qu'il y ait une prise de conscience il
faut qu'il y ait un débat qui soit mené
de manière publique et je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est notre
notre volonté c'est que il y ait une
suite assez recommandations et nous
allons d'ailleurs aller voir toutes les
quatre la ministre Isabelle Rome pour
lui présenter notre notre rapport et
vous avez déjà une date écoutez c'est
rapidement oui très rapidement sur ce
que disait sur la responsabilité
finalement la responsabilité des
spectateurs de de ces vidéos porno
est-ce que vous diriez qu'il y a c'est
de la méconnaissance c'est-à-dire on
regarde une vidéo porno on sait pas ce
qui se cache derrière ou c'est les
responsabilités
c'est compliqué de répondre à cette
question parce que je pense qu'on peut
pas ignorer que ce qu'on voit en face de
l'écran c'est exactement
la réalité on se doute qu'il y a des
coulisses donc après je pense qu'aussi
il y a un déni dans cette façon de de
consommer la pornographie et je pense
que l'utilisateur n'a pas envie
finalement de poser toutes ces questions
là notre rapport et le travail qu'on a
voulu faire c'est justement de d'ouvrir
les yeux et que toutes les parties
prenantes de l'industrie pornographique
et connaissances des pratiques de ce qui
se passe voilà c'est un état des lieux
avec des recommandations qu'on formule
qui sont là pour éclairer et pour
essayer surtout de protéger le je crois
que le verbe qu'on utilise le plus dans
ce rapport c'est la protection des
femmes qui sont victimes avec le droit à
l'oubli qu'elles ont droit aussi et bien
sûr la protection des enfants déjà des
mineurs vous le disiez vous avez
auditionné évidemment des actrices porno
pour ce rapport on va écouter l'une
d'entre elles l'une de vos auditions
c'est Nikita bel outil à part de ses
conditions de travail
la scène qu'ils ont tourné avec moi m'a
laissé la mère saveur d'avoir été un
soir de 2012 la victime d'un abus de
faiblesse et d'un non respect évident
mon consentement j'ai été la victime
d'une façon de faire d'une méthode de
fabrication qui n'a rien à voir avec le
métier qui est le mien mais qui fait
tâche avec l'industrie que je défends
pierre encore c'est joints sont les
rejetons d'un système d'une méthode de
production qui n'a que faire des
actrices ou plutôt des amatrices qui
rêvent d'une carrière glamour à la Clara
Morgane qui n'existe aucun véritable
statut aucune légitimité aucune
existence légale pour les acteurs et les
actrices qui œuvrent dans la
pornographie en France si elles sont
actrices pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas de
syndicats interprofessionnels pour
défendre leurs intérêts si elles sont
actrices pourquoi n'existe-t-il pas
d'agence pour protéger les débutants de
des mauvaises personnes
est-ce qu'il faut comprendre Laurence
Cohen que ces actrices sont avant tout
des victimes en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
a pu constater au niveau du rapport même
si on a effectivement pu auditionner des
actrices des productrices qui essayent
de faire ce qu'elles ont des Nobé
finalement une pornographie éthique mais
moi je sais c'est possible pour vous
après avoir travaillé sur ce rapport ça
existe la pornographie alors c'est
infinitésimal par rapport à
l'industrie pornographique et je pense
que c'est ça n'est pas possible en ce
sens où il y a une demande j'avais parlé
d'addiction il y a une demande de plus
en plus forte sur des contenus qui sont
des contenus violents et donc éthique et
pornographie c'est complètement
antagoniste mais ce qu'on a voulu faire
également dans nos recommandations c'est
faire en sorte de créer une au niveau
des violences de la pornographie un
délit d'incitation à une infraction
pénale c'est à dire que il pas des
possibilités au niveau législatif de de
faire en sorte de stopper ces violences
qui sont des violences extrêmes on a
entendu parmi les témoignages des jeunes
femmes qui finalement répondaient à des
petites annonces mais qui quand elles se
trouvaient sur place vivaient des choses
qui sont inimaginables et votre rapport
et l'interroge aussi beaucoup la notion
de consentement ah bah on voit
clairement que la notion de consentement
n'existe pas en fait du tout et que rien
n'est encadré
tikita Bellucci qui s'est exprimée tout
à l'heure à clairement à le défend
justement toutes les femmes qui ont été
victimes donc on se rend compte
finalement que il y a pas de contrat
rien n'est stipulé dans le contrat et
puis s'il devait être écrit quelque
chose bah une fois que la caméra est en
route et bien la scène se déroule
complètement différemment et que sous
l'effet des projecteurs et comme ce sont
la plupart du temps des femmes
vulnérables et précaires et bien elle
subissent ce genre d'action donc il y a
une audition que nous ne pourrez pas
montrer puisque elle a été à huis clos
on a entendu des témoignages qui
vraiment
dramatique on est encore bouleversé de
ce qu'on a pu entendre des témoignages
vraiment très forts
et même une jeune femme qui nous
racontait qu'à midi et leur servait à
manger la même chose que le chien
voilà des témoignages vraiment qui sont
bouleversants donc je veux dire notre
rapport il est pas il est il est juste
il est juste en fait le reflet de du
travail qu'on a pu mener cette enquête
finalement grâce à ses auditions et ses
témoignages mais qui sont vraiment
fidèles à ce qu'on a pu entendre donc on
a essayé d'être le plus neutre possible
mais en tout cas on a essayé de faire
ressortir ce qu'on a entendu et je crois
que voilà ce rapport était attendu parce
que personne n'avait osé mettre la main
dedans et je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a
eu le courage de le faire aussi pour le
souligner c'était pas voilà c'était un
travail qui était passionnant maintenant
on espère qu'une chose c'est que
justement ils servent à mieux protéger
ceux qui en sont les victimes est-ce
qu'on voit aussi dans votre rapport
c'est qu'il y a une forme de Tournon
avec le développement d'Internet le
développement des réseaux sociaux aussi
ça a changé beaucoup de choses dans
l'industrie pornographique et ça a
changé beaucoup de choses pour ces
femmes oui oui ça y est il y a un
tournant très important qui s'est opéré
avec donc une recherche de contenu de
plus en plus de plus en plus violent et
qui se base sur le fait que les femmes
finalement sont à disposition et elles
peuvent subir les pires choses parce que
finalement ça ce sont des fantasmes
essentiellement masculins donc les
femmes sont traitées comme des des
objets et c'est très important de
pouvoir le dénoncer en discuter
travailler aussi à l'éducation au niveau
de l'école donc on a parmi les
recommandations
insistés sur le fait qu'il fallait
recruter des personnels pour travailler
sur ces questions là pour mettre en
garde pour faire prendre conscience
parce qu'on a eu aussi quand on est allé
dans un établissement dans dans mon
département on a eu aussi des
témoignages de jeunes filles qui nous
disaient que en fait ce qu'il voit dans
des films pornographiques pour eux ça
devient la norme et donc la norme c'est
le garçon hyper viril qui impose des
choses violentes et la fille qui subit
et il y a pas du tout dans ses
rapports-là d'égalité ni de droit au
plaisir partagé
voilà et ça c'est extrêmement important
de le déconstruire au niveau de l'école
normalement il y a une éducation
sexuelle et à la vie sexuelle et
affective or on le sait bien et nous au
niveau de la délégation on en était
moins en réalité c'est très peu pratiqué
ça dépend des établissements il y a
beaucoup d'inégalités donc il faut qu'il
y ait des moyens qui qui soient qui soit
donnés au niveau de l'éducation
nationale ça se joue dès le plus jeune
âge finalement je crois qu'il faut
sensibiliser au plus jeunes et que il
faut arrêter d'en faire un sujet tabou
puisque aujourd'hui les victimes ce
justement des écoliers des collégiens
donc je crois que c'est aussi le rôle de
l'école parce que parfois ce sont des
sujets qui sont très difficiles
d'aborder à la maison mais les
conséquences sont tellement importantes
que je crois que ça vaut le coup quand
même de sensibiliser les jeunes et de
leur dire que se mettent en photo sur
Instagram ou sur snapchat à moitié
dénudés et bien il y a un risque et que
cette photo elle va elle va rester toute
la vie toute leur vie derrière eux donc
je crois qu'il faut vraiment aborder le
sujet
oser pour essayer peut-être de
déconstruire des stéréotypés des
stéréotypes arrêter cette banalisation
et voilà le respect du corps aussi c'est
important d'en parler et je crois que
les les collégiens vivent ça sans trop
pouvoir en parler et que créer des
espaces de parole au sein
d'établissement scolaire à mon sens
comme on peut sensibiliser sur les
stupéfiants et sur d'autres pratiques
néfastes je pense que c'est un sujet
qu'il faut vraiment aborder c'est l'un
des points aussi de notre rapport
de cette porosité entre pornographie et
prostitution on va écouter un autre
extrait de vos auditions c'est Elvire à
regui que vous avez additionné qui est
la chef de l'Office central pour la
répression de la traite des êtres
humains on écoute
la porosité entre le monde de la
prostitution et celui de la pornographie
est évidente
vous l'avez largement d'ailleurs évoqué
dans les travaux de votre table ronde
dont j'ai pris connaissance
j'ajouterai simplement que mes
enquêteurs dans leur travail quotidien
sur internet pour démanteler des réseaux
de proxénétisme
tombe très régulièrement sur des
annonces vantant l'expérience dans le
domaine de la pornographie des
prostituées
il y a un acronyme bien connu de mes
enquêteurs qui s'appelle PSE pour une
Stone expérience donc ça veut tout dire
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on se soigne
la frontière entre pornographie et
prostitution elle est plus que tenue oui
tout à fait et puis on peut faire aussi
on voit qu'il y a au niveau des
recrutements cette porosité et puis on
peut faire un lien aussi avec ces
réseaux on a dit que c'était quand même
producteur diffuseur etc gagnait
énormément énormément d'argent que donc
il y avait un intérêt financier j'ai
parlé j'ai parlé de de milliards donc on
voit toute
l'industrie du porno aujourd'hui à
plusieurs milliards 8 milliards et donc
on voit bien que c'est rentable là on
est on est on parle de manière c'est
assez cynique de le dire comme ça c'est
pour ça que dans nos recommandations on
ne se contente pas de parler
de choses de des il faut des tout ce
qu'on a dit sur les débats etc mais on
essaye aussi de créer des mesures dans
le niveau pénal pour pouvoir faire en
sorte protéger les victimes et puis par
exemple le retrait de contenu illicite
quand il y a une demande du d'une
victime il faut absolument que les
vidéos soient retirées de manière
gratuite alors que ça a été souligné
c'est plus que ce qu'elles ont elles ont
pu toucher donc il y a des mesures de
protection et puis à un moment donné pas
forcément de droit l'oubli en plus même
si même si et puis il faut aussi faire
en sorte que au niveau de l'art comme il
y a des possibilités d'infliger des
amendes et des amandes qui soient
absolument dissuasives et on a aussi
demandé que
au niveau de Pharos il y est la forme de
signalement du ministère de l'Intérieur
voilà qui est la sous forme de
signalement il y est justement les
violences sexuelles qu'ils soient ou
élargi au niveau de farose qui aiderait
à retirer les contenus et à tout de
suite intervenir ce qui est fait
d'ailleurs dans la lutte à juste titre
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme et
bien là il faut le faire également
concernant ces violences pornographiques
un point parce qu'effectivement les
recommandations sont nombreuses un point
de recommandation de ce rapport 23 23
parmi toutes ces recommandations il y a
des mesures qui visent à protéger vous
l'avez dit les plus jeunes de ces
contenus pornographiques vous demandez
notamment à ce que l'arcom l'autorité
publique de régulation de l'audiovisuel
soit assermenté afin que ces agents
puissent eux-mêmes constater les
infractions des sites accessibles aux
mineurs vous suggérez également
d'imposer aussi de porno l'affichage
d'un écran noir tant que l'âge de
l'internaute n'a pas été correctement
vérifié autre type de recommandations il
concerne la protection des femmes le
rapport penche pour la création d'un
vrai droit à l'oubli en apaisant en
plateforme de se plier
parfaitement aux demandes de retrait de
vidéo formulées par les personnes qui
sont filmées et puis enfin des
recommandations plus culturelles disons
le Sénat demande à ce que les parents
soient mieux sensibilisés aux enjeux de
la pornographie vous proposez de faire
de la lutte contre les violences
pornographiques une priorité de
politique publique Alexandra évidemment
l'un des points de ce rapport c'est la
protection des mineurs c'est évidemment
une question clé Steve Lady il y a la
question du blocage des sites notamment
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment bloquer
l'accès à ces sites et notamment
évidemment à des mineurs et ce qui a un
problème de manque de coordination entre
l'arcom qui est l'autorité de régulation
et c'est fournisseurs de site internet
manifestement oui puisque aujourd'hui
c'est pas possible pour eux de réussir à
bloquer les sites donc je pense que ce
qu'on disait à l'instant c'est qu'il
faut donner plus de moyens justement à
l'arcome pour qu'il puisse avoir cette
autorité qui permettrait donc de bloquer
les sites donc au minimum techniquement
c'est de faire un écran noir on a vu que
des chaînes de télévision quand elle
diffusait des films pornographiques
elles avaient un système de cryptage
donc pourquoi les sites internet ne le
fer pas et puis nous on a rencontré des
entreprises qui proposaient comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure des solutions
techniques de reconnaissance faciale qui
a un nom prêt arrive à mesurer l'âge de
de l'internaute du visiteur du site donc
voilà c'est tout est prêt il y a plus
qu'à j'ai envie de dire mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui notre rapport il est là
aussi pour dire qu'il y a urgence et que
la médiation que propose l'air comme
jusqu'à présent alors que cette article
du code pénal et cette loi a été votée
maintenant il y a deux ans voilà il ne
peut plus attendre donc il est urgent
d'agir aujourd'hui d'essayer de protéger
nos mineurs pourquoi la loi n'est pas
appliquée on l'a dit un article du code
pénal qui qui sanctionne théoriquement
la diffusion de ces images vers les
mineurs pourquoi c'est pas appliqué
c'est quoi c'est qu'est-ce qui bloque
ben je pense aujourd'hui que l'arcom a
encore des difficultés justement à
saisir les sites internet c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont demandé une médiation
peut-être pour prendre le temps aussi
nous c'est ce qu'on dénonce donc je
pense qu'il faut donner aussi plus de
moyens comme je le disais à l'arcom pour
qu'il puisse agir de manière concrète
voilà ce n'est plus acceptable
aujourd'hui qu'on puisse qu'un mineur
savoir accès en tapant dans un moteur de
recherche n'importe quel mot à des
contenus pornographiques mais très
violents je pense que donc il y a les
moyens à donner mais il y a aussi une
volonté politique et je crois aussi que
la pornographie n'est pas appréhendée
dans tout ce qu'on a révélé au niveau de
notre rapport il y a un espèce
d'imagerie un peu romantique ou je ne
sais quoi mais qui n'existe absolument
pas qui n'existe je sais pas si ça a
déjà existé mais en tout cas là elle
n'existe pas du tout et ce sont des
contenus qui sont violents et plus les
contenus sont violents plus il y a une
demande de celles et ceux qui regardent
de contenu encore plus violent donc il y
a une véritable une véritable escalade
donc il faut une volonté politique pour
faire cesser ces violences et donc il
faut les encadrer et il y a des outils
nous en avons ajouté d'autres et donc
maintenant et bien il faut que on s'en
appartenant sur les outils vous avez
envisagé de fonctionner les
consommateurs de porno non ça a jamais
été discuté vous c'est pas une mesure
qui on est si vous voulez pour l'instant
parce que c'est quand même un éventail
important et un gros travail pour
l'instant on est sur une sensibilité des
avertissements puisque on souhaite
également qu'il y ait non seulement il y
a bon l'histoire de l'écran noir par
rapport au mineur etc mais pour le
public on va dire adulte il y ait des
avertissements pour dire que ce sont des
actes qui ne sont pas
simulés et que ça peut ouvrir à des
infractions pénales etc donc si vous
voulez sensibilisation débat
éducation au niveau de l'école alerte au
niveau des parents qui ne sont pas tous
obligatoirement au fait au fait de ce
qui se passe au niveau des smartphones
etc donc voilà petit à petit il faut
qu'il y ait une progression de la prise
de conscience et des choses à mon avis
et pour conclure justement puisque le
but de votre apport vous l'avez dit
c'était d'alerter l'opinion publique
mais aussi le gouvernement vous allez
rencontrer la ministre dans les
prochains jours qu'est-ce que vous
attendez aujourd'hui concrètement des
mesures concrètes du gouvernement et qui
puissent se saisir que dans le débat
public on puisse aborder la pornographie
il voit que depuis quelques années que
les violences faites aux femmes ont été
au cœur de des politiques publiques
qu'elle soit mis en place un peu partout
avec une certaine prise de conscience on
l'espère aujourd'hui qu'avec les
violences sexuelles qui peuvent être
perpétrées dans l'industrie
pornographique ça peut être ça peut être
aussi un sujet majeur auquel il faut
s'atteler quand une une actrice victime
de violences sexuelle durant un tournage
va déposer plainte elle doit être pris
au sérieux quand elle dépose plainte
pour viol et que voilà tout cet arsenal
aujourd'hui doit être
doit être discutée que ce soit dans
l'espace familial donc on est là aussi
pour alerter les les parents de les
pères de famille justement sur l'usage
méconnu de leurs enfants qui sont eux
très très alertés très au fait de ce qui
se passe et un dernier mot on rentre
quand même la taille elle se joue au
niveau du gouvernement est-ce qu'elle se
joue aussi au niveau européen alors oui
justement on a voulu évidemment
travailler sur notre pays mais il est
extrêmement important d'avoir une
collaboration au niveau européen et au
niveau aussi international parce que
c'est c'est juteux au niveau
international et juste pour conclure
peut-être quand même rendre hommage aux
trois associations qui ont qui ont
beaucoup travaillé aux îles féminisme le
nid et les effrontés parce qu'elles nous
ont alerté aussi un coup de chapeau au
parquet de Paris parce que c'est eux qui
ont mené l'enquête donc c'est pour ça
aussi que dans notre rapport on demande
des renforcements de moyens au niveau de
la justice au niveau de la police des
formations etc parce que chapeau bas
quoi ils ont fait quand même un travail
important qui ont permis de mettre en
lumière et bravo pour votre travail et
j'invite tous ceux qui regardent à lire
ce rapport qui est parfois glaçant mais
qui est riche en enseignements et qui
alertent effectivement sur du porno et
on suivra évidemment avec vous les
suites de ce rapport suite donné
notamment par le gouvernement merci
mesdames d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]